[Musique]
je contiens c'est la chasse au trésor
bonjour
10 minutes 10 minutes et là c'est là le
ça y est nous venons de trouver le
premier indice
dans le salon tu auras la moins qu'on le
savon le salon le salon vif le salon
Sylvie
vous rentrez pas tous dans la maison
c'est la chanson trésor monsieur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où se
trouve
le trésor
l'indice on a 8 minutes Paris 7 minutes
indice je peux pas vous dire
Pascal
on n'est pas chez la bonne personne vous
êtes trompé
bonjour monsieur le poulailler le
poulailler s'il vous plaît
poulailler il est où Monsieur c'est la
concentré vite
il reste 8 minutes
comment sont les œufs paris les œufs
sont jaunes non c'est pas celui-là je la
tape stop
oh non c'est pas le bon
homme
dans le salon tu suivras mes
instructions
le salon le salon venez suivez-moi
le troisième indice dans la cuisine va
fouiller dans la farine la cuisine la
cuisine vite vite vite vite
attention
[Musique]
il nous reste plus que 2 minutes
nous avons donc la quatrième et dernière
énigme je suppose
dans la chambre à coucher tu vas pas
trouver
la chambre à coucher elle est rouge
vas-y fouille-toi fouille fouille
doucement oh là là
c'est la carte top c'est la carte c'est
la carte du Trésor Paris
[Musique]